[Music]
this is the story of an international
man of botany a man who traveled across
every continent besides antarctica in
search of precious seeds and foreign
produce he dodged arrows in the melee
islands almost fell to his death in the
andes and caught and overcame deadly
diseases all so he could bring back new
specimens to the u.s of a
this is the story of david fairchild
i'm sarah burnett i'm the vice president
of wellness and food policy at panera
bread
not only did david fairchild change the
way americans eat forever but he
stumbled upon the main attraction of our
new grain bowls quinoa
so to find out more about fairchild i
traveled to miami florida and visited
what was once the home of david
fairchild the ultimate food curator
hi
i'm craig morrell director of the
kampong of the national tropical
botanical garden
welcome to dr fairchild's garden
david fairchild was born in 1869
and with a real penchant for food and
for travel and for plants
at the age of 22 he opened up the office
of seed and plant introduction in
washington dc rapidly becoming the chief
plant collector for the us department of
agriculture
thanks to him we have mangoes dates
cotton soybeans bamboo and yes quinoa
to tell us more about fairchild
adventures i turned to chief explorer
chad husby i'm chad husby and this is
the fairchild tropical botanic garden
this fig tree grew from a seed david
fairchild collected in the philippines
in 1939.
we thumb through fairchild's old photos
and correspondence it's amazing the
amount that he documented
and he has notes here like saying well i
got seeds of these and brought them back
to washington dc
[Music]
fairchild stumbled upon quinoa in 1898.
the diet of ink has once revolved around
it but before he could pass his specimen
on to his colleagues fairchild almost
died
high in the andes his mule slipped and
lost its footing on a patch of ice at
the edge of a canyon the mule kicked and
bucked and fairchild grabbed at whatever
mud or ice he could find
until there was nothing left to grab
just as a thousand foot drop seemed
imminent the mule hoisted itself up
the quinoa was safe
in 2005 it was deemed a superfood and
has been a darling of brain bowls across
the country ever since
fairchild was a true culinary curator
and it's thanks to him that we have such
diverse selection of foods to choose
from
it's up to panera to continue to curate
delicious healthful foods for our
customers
and who knows what exciting food we'll
introduce next